.
J'y suis allé tôt ce matin à la
ntntntntntntntntntntntntntntntn.
M. Charette.
- Un plaisir de vousP1P1P1P1P1P.
- À la Place Québec, on est
ici... c'est ici l l le Québec
va recevoir les États fédérés.
- Vous en profitez, de la COP15,
pour annoncecécécécécécécécécécz
la liste, vous revoyez la liste.
Donnez l l les grandes lignes.
Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire?
BENOIT CHARETTE, ministre,
Eneseseseseseseseseseseseseseset
au niveau faunique que
orororistique. Au niveau
floristique, il n'y avait pas
eu d'ajout depuis 2012. Donc,'a.
Au niveau faunique, depuis 2009.
Donc, on recule encore plus
loin. Une quarantaine d'espèces
statuer sur leur habitat.
On d d d décrire leur habitat
parce que sans protéger
en rien son rétablissement.
On vient aussi déterminer s'il
vulnérable ou menacée selon
la précarité de l'espèce
à jour, hein. Si on avait
à résumé ça, c'est une mise
- Les grenouilles, dont
on a beaucoup parlé.
- La rainette à faux-grillon.
à faux-grillon... entre
un projet de condos puis
les grenouilles, est-ce que ça
veut dire qu'on va plus se
- On l'a vu avec ce qui s'est
passé récemment sur laddddd
de Montréal, à Longueuil
en particulier, il faut
dedededededededededededededededs
cas, ça veut dire : modifier
un projet. Dans certains cas, ça
veut dire : réorienter, sinon
empêcher le développemaiaiaiaias
tous les cas, lorsqu'une espèce,
ça offre des moyens,
des budgets, pour le ddededededu
rétablissement de l'espèce
en question.
- Donc
aux développeurs est plusgrgrgr.
- Oui, en fait, ça oblige
le promoteur à adapterueueueueu.
- L'objectif du Québec, comme
du Canada : 2030, 30 % de terres
protégées, d'espaces protégés,
mais
l'impression, dans le nord
du Québe là là là là là là où
c'est plus grand, plus facile.
Dans le sud du Québec, autour
de Montréal, une vraie ceinture
de terres agricoles qu'on donne
aux développeurs. Quand est-ce
là-dessus?
- C'est très vaste,
hein, le Québec. 1 % de
17 000 km2. Donc, on a accompli
un exploit incroyable
au précédent mandat; passé
de 10 à 17 %, mais oui, on adede
dans le nord à la demande
des communautés autochtones.
Là, le défi, puis je vous le d
entre vous et entre nous,
au cours des prochains jours,
dans le cadre de la COP, o
mettre beaucoup l'emphase
sur les mesures dans le sud
pour rétablir un certain
équilibre, que ce soit à travers
l'acquisits s s s s s s privées,
que ce soit à travers des terres
publiq
dans certains cas, transformées
en aeseseseseseses. Mais on est
conscient qu'on doit mettre
justement, bien représentéinini.
- Donc, Laurentides, Montérégie,
protéger, là.
- Laurenti
symbolique qui est celui
du Mont-Kaaikop, dont on entend
parler
Les promoteurs devraient nous
présenter leur projet dans les
qui fait l'unanimité, autant au
niveau des milieux économiques
c'est réclamé.
- Avez-vous... donnez-moi
une idée des espaces qu'on va
qu'on a une idée de tant à tante
comme gouvernement, c'est
un mandat 2022-2026. Moi,
à la fin du mandat, on soitibibe
protection sur notre territoire
et
2030 pour aller chercher
u'u'u'u'u'u'u'u'u'il nous
manque. Mais l'essentiel,
dans le sud.
- Oui.esesesesesesesesest très .
Les caribous!
- Oui.
- En fait, non. On a eu
q q q q q q q q q qui a déposé
son rapport il y a quelque mois
avec une entente avec
On a un échéancier. On a uneded.
Donc, d'ici juin normalement,
on devrait annoncer laioioioioin
du gouvernement fédéral.OnOnOnO,
cette fois, réellement menacée.
- C'est impr O O O O O O O O O r
dans la grande plénière
rejoindre Jean Lemire...
-... qui est un des Québécois
qui sera le plus prè
Alors, à tout de suite.
- Merci bien.
- M. Lemire, bonnjnjnjnjnjnjnjn.
- Ça va bien?
- Ça va bien.
- Alors voilà...
onusien.
- Est-ce que ce n'est pas
devenu, je ne vous le pose
à vous, Jean Lemire, mais trop
gros? ninininininininininininin.
- Exactement.
- Est-ce que ça ne rend pas
la tâche herculéenne?chchchchch.
clim. et enjeux nord. arct., Qc
- C'est très difficile parce
qu'idéalement, dans un système
150 pays qui s
40 contre. Bon, bien parfait.
Mais ce n'est pas ça.
chose de fantastique, c'est
qu'une fois qu'on s'est entendu,
tout le monde est d'accord
tout le monde avance.
atatatatatatatatatatatatiques,
les gaz à effet de serre,
c'est facile à f f f f f f f f ,
mais c'est facile à mesurer.
- Oui.
- Comment on mesure puison s'ene
des marqueurs? Ce n'es
ça le défi?
- Absolument. Absolument.
avez entendu parler de
cette protection
bon et bien là évidemment,
il y a des définitions qui
on a décidé de faire différent
de l'anc
si on veut, c'est que là on se
met des balises ns le temps
en mesure de mieux suivre parce.
Donc là, on est vraiment dans
ambitieux, beaucoup plus précis
et qui se calculent et se
mesurent dans le temps.
quand ce sera fini la semaine
prochaine, le succès ou
l'insuccès de cette conférence-.
- Exactement. m m m m m m m m m,
moi, j'aime appeler le "moment
crée ça. Je n'ai jamais vu,
moi, autant de mobilisation,
autant en société civile,
vraiment dans une mobilisation
exceptionnelle. Donc, en ce
moment, ça ne va pas très bienau
du texte de négociation,
ça avance très lentement. Mais
les petits miracles arriveCOCOÇa
être dans les derniers
Ça va jouer serrer. Il va y
avoir beaucoup de prntntntntntn,
qu'on ait ce petit
- On a besoin d'un petit
miracle, certa e e e e e e e e n
canadienne, le Qué
le ministre M. Guilbeault,
l'autre ministre... comment
- Bien en fait, on fait part
nous, de la délégation
onusien bien sûr, mais on aararr
puisqu'on représente l'ensemblet
le porte-par
ces gouvernements-là. Pensez
à la Californie, à l'Écosse.
province, etc. Donc, ça nous
particulier parce qu'on est
à la table de négociations.
c'est mon siège. On est..., là?
- Oui, exactement. Juste ici.
intervient.- Quand le ministre ,
vous allez où, vous? Vous avez
M. Guilbeault?
- Je pourrais aller aux côtés
de Monsieur Lemire au 'e'e'e'e't
un privilège pour le Québec
quand même.
- Et Benoit Charette,s s s s s t
les choses de la même façon?
- En fait, le fédéral,
le gouvernement canadienéeéeéeét
canadien mise beaucoup
le leadership des provinces. Et
le Québec, parmi les provincesét
ce que l'on fa
en termes de protection du
territoire, c'est quelque chose
peut comptabiliser à son tour.
Donc, une belle collaboration.
e!e!e!e!e!e!e!e!e!e!e!e!e!e!e!e!
- Ah, il y a du monde
- Un moment donné, est-ce que..e
qu'il n'y a pas trop de monde
pour s'entendre?
de venir dans une de nos séancez
un texte qui est à l'écran
et vous avez 196 c
la virgule. C'est très complexes
ce processus-là trouvent ça,
on arrive avec un texte à la fia
qui est important.
- Merci Messieurs. Bonne COP15.
- On va suivre ça au cours p p y
aura des moments bas, puis là,
prolongation sûre
- Prenez pas de rendez-vous
pour le 20!
(rires)